شكرا ليال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نواصل واياكم
تغطيه التطورات في السودان في تصريحات
مهمه للعربيه اكد الجيش السوداني انه لا
يوجد تفاوض مع قوه الدعم السريع سواء في
جنوب السودان او دوله اخرى في الوقت
الحالي واكد الجيش السوداني ان المعركه
الان لحسم ما وصفه بتفلت قوات الدعم
السريع ولدحرها من الخرطوم وفي تصريحاته
للعربيه اوضح الجيش السوداني ان رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان لم يسافر
لدوله اخرى للقاء من وصفه بقائد التمرد في
اشاره لقائد قوات الدعم السريعه محمد
حمدان دقلو
[موسيقى]
التصريحات الاخيره للجيش السوداني تاتي
رغما اعلان وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
دينجلور خلال لقاء مع العربيه دينك دلو ان
الرئيس سالفير ميارديت تحدث مع البرهان
وابلغه بمقترح عقد لقاء مع حماتي مشيرا
الى ان البرهان رحب بالمقترح دون ان يتخذ
موقفه النهائي بالرفض او الموافقه
المقترح هو التالي
طالب رئيس بان تجري محادثات بين القاعدين
حول كيف يمكن ايقاف الحرب
[موسيقى]
ثانيا
هذا الاجتماع المقترح يمكن ان يكون في
داخل السودان او خارجها
[موسيقى]
لم يغادروا جنوب السوداني ابدا ولكن
يمكن ان يغادر السودان اذا ما وافق على
هذا المقترح
ورئيسنا نتحدث مع رئيس البرهان والبرهان
تلقى هذا المقترح وقال
نرد لرئيس سيلفاكير كما ان حميدتي
المسؤول عن اتصالاتنا في الخرطوم يحاول
الوصول اليه
وليقدم له المقترح الخطي
كما قدموها للبرهان
وبشان تمديد الهدنه في السودان اوضح وزير
خارجيه جنوب السودان ان الجيش والدعم
السريع لم يوافق بعد على طلب
الرئيسا لم يتم التاكيد عليه بعد ولكنه
قدم الى الطرفين
الرئيس البرهان
تلقى الطلب ولكننا لا نستطيع ان نتحدث عن
ردعي من الطرفين لانه وقف اطلق النار لم
يتم الاتفاق عليهم الموافق عليهم قبل اي
من الطرفين
سفير جزر القمر في فرنسا وعضو مبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه كان اكد هو
الاخر في لقاء مع العربيه ان طرفي النزاع
وفقا على مبادره افريقيه للتسويه وان هذه
المبادره تتضمن وقفا دائما للنار وان رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي يعتزم زياره الخرطوم
شرطه توفر الضمانات الامنيه
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع الدولي الى ان يقفوا على
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل ايجاد حل
طريقي
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه
سياده اللواء اهلا بكم معنا ما حقيقه
الامر اذا بين كل هذه التصريحات التي تقول
بمفاوضات وامكانيات قبول تفاوض بين
الطرفين وبين نفي الجيش السوداني
مساء الخير مرحب بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين
هذه المبادرات دخلت الان
حيز الابعاد كانت اقوال قبل يومين واضح
انه مجلس الامني اعطى الضوء الاخضر
للاتحاد الافريقي حتى يتدخل في الازمه
السودانيه وبدات العمل الاتصالات كما ورد
في التقرير
هنالك دعم من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لهذه المبادره الليليهود مجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي مباشره
وهنالك رئيس جنوب السودان وجيبوتي وكينيا
هم الاستعداد للحضور الى الخصوم
الاجابات طبعا الان دبلوماسيه
بما يختص بالهدنه فيما يختص بترحيب بالغاء
وسيتم الرد الصوره الرسميه في الساعات
القادمه لكن عموما اعتقد معلومات زياده
اللواء بانه
السلطات السودانيه سترد في الساعات
القادمه على هذا الطرح الافريقي
يتم مدارسه الامر الان وترتيب الجهات
الدبلوماسيه وبالتالي بيتم الرد الدعم
السريع طبعا الى الان لم تصل اليه
الدعوه واضح انه من حديث السيد الوزير
الخارجيه الجنوب السودان
وبالتالي قد يكون هنالك تاخير طبعا لازم
يكون الرد من الجانبين
للجهه التي تدخل بالمفاوضات وبالتالي من
الناحيه السياسيه والدبلوماسيه لا يمكن
التعويل على طرف واحد ما لم يتم اخذ
موافقه للطرفين وبالتالي بيكون هنالك ضمان
يكون هنالك نوع من التحضير لما بعد وقت له
النار
لمعرفه سعر العمليه السياسيه والسلميه في
السودان
طيبه بس لواء الجيش قال للعربيه انه لا
يوجد تفاوض سواء في جنوب السودان او في
دوله اخرى وانه المعركه الان لحسم ما وصفه
بتفلت قوات الدعم السريع ولدحرها من
الخرطوم يعني في تناقض حضرتك شايف بين هذا
الكلام وبين نوايا التفاوض يعني اذا قبل
الجيش دخول احد او دوله ما على الخط
بالنتيجه سيجلس الطرفان سويا اليس كذلك
طبعا هنالك قناتين واضح انه او قناه
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه مستمره
بعملياتها العسكريه عمليات المطارده
والتنشيط والقناه الاخرى هي القناه
السياسيه هي مكتب رئيس مجلس السياده
السياسيه تتعامل عبر وزاره الخارجيه مع ما
يرد من اتصالات وتصريحات لكن عموما في
تنسيق بين الجانبين بانه وبالتالي لم يتم
الرد حتى الان يعني الى الان لم يتم الرد
كل الانظار الى الى الجانب الحكومي للقوات
المسلحه بينما الجانب الاخر الى الان لم
تصل الدعوه
ولم اعتقد انه من المبكر الان التفكير في
كيف يرد الجيش السوداني ولماذا تريد ان
تقول ربما بانتظار تصريحات قوات الدعم
السريع ومن ثم نسمع الى موقف نهائي نستمع
الى موقف نهائي من الجيش
بالضبط
في هذا الحوار سياده اللواء سؤالي بس قبل
ان اعود اليك بعد قليل باختصار ايضا لو
سمحت انت فرقت الان بين مجلس السياده
والجيش تعتقد بانه الجيش يمكن ان يقدم
نفسه على انه لا يزال يحارب التمرد كما
يسميه وبالتالي يوفد اعضاء من مجلس
السياده هم الذين يفاوضون قوات الدعم
السريع هل هذا ممكن بالمعنى العسكري
والسياسي في ان
لا هي هي قناتين منفصلات انا تحدثت عن
القناه السياسيه مجلس السياده كجهه سياسيه
سياديه ووزاره الخارجيه ايرانه الاخرى
قناه القوات المسلحه الذي تاخذها الان
عمليات ضد هو متمرده ما عندها علاقه بما
يحدث في مجال السياسي هذه قناتين مختلفات
بس كيف يعني بصير العمل باي خط
يعمل اولا وعبر اي اطراف يعني مجلس
السياده يعمل باي اتجاه تقصد والجيش يعمل
باي اتجاه التفاوض بده يكون عسكري
بالبدايه قبل ما يكون سياسي صحيح
وبعد انتهاء الاتصالات غالبا في مثل هذه
الظروف بيتم الاتصالات السياسيه وبعدك
بتنزل الاضرار السياسي
العسكريات المسلحه وبالتالي بيقوم بتنسيق
بين الجانبين لانه المجلس مجلس واحد مجلس
الدفاع والامني والعقد بكامل هيئته والان
بخوض العمليات وبالتالي عند انتهاء
الخطوات السياسيه ينتقل الى القرار
السياسي العسكري الى القياده العسكريه
وبالتالي بتبدا خطوات هذه مهمه عسكريه
بعدها بيتم التشاور في كيفيه الجلوس كيفيه
التفاوض وهل سيكون بين الرؤساء نفسهم او
بين
القيادات والذي يقوم بمناديب داخل السودان
او خارج السودان كل هذه الامور متروكه
تفاصيل تمام ساعود اليك بعد قليل سياده
اللواء دكتور ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا
مصدر صحفي قلل العربيه ان العشرات قتلوا
في اشتباكات في ولايه دارفور وافاد المصدر
ان اشتباكات في مدينه الجنينه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تحولت الى قتال قبلي ادى
الى مقتل العشرات واوضح ان الاشتباكات
وقعت بين قبيله المساليت والقبائل الاخرى
في الجنينه غربا دارفور من جهتها اعلنت
القبائل العربيه في بيان وقفه اطلاق النار
فورا داعيه منسوبيها كافه لضبط النفس
والالتزام الفوري بذلك
وبالاضافه لا تزال الاشتباكات دائره في
عدد من المناطق السودانيه وبالاخص في
العاصمه الخرطوم نتعرف على تفاصيل اكثر
حول ذلك مع ليال
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل انفجرت الاوضاع
داخل السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مناطق جغرافيه متباعده في هذا البلد
الشاسع شمالا مشاهدينا في مروي في الوسط
في الخرطوم وفي الغرب في دارفورت الان في
الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات يبدو
بان نقاط ونطاق هذه المواجهه الحاميه بين
الطرفين اصبحت اكثر تركيزا داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم اذا هذه العاصمه التي يقال عنها
مثلثه لماذا لانها تتكون من ثلاث تجمعات
سكانيه كما نتابع هنا
الخرطوم بحري ام درمان والخرطوم مدينه
الخرطوم جنوبا يمكن لنا ان نقول ان معظم
الاشتباكات الدائره الان في مدينه الخرطوم
الجنوبيه تنحصر حول نقطتين اساسيتين كما
نشاهد هنا قياده الولاده العامه للجيش
السوداني والمطار حول المطار هنا يقول
الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم السريع
تسيطر على المطر اما قياده الجيش القياده
العامه فيسعى الطرفان الان للسيطره عليها
لماذا لان هذه النقطه تعتبر استراتيجيه
بمسار هذا النزاع الدائر بين الطرفين اذا
تنحصر المواجهه حول المطار وحول القياده
العامه حيث توجد اشتباكات حاميه بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع في الخارج اما النقطه
الثالثه
للاشتباكات فهي طبعا شرق المطار تقع
اشتباكات في حي الرياض كما نشاهد هنا كما
تقع اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري غربي المطار واشتباكات اخرى في
حي الصحافه وفي حي جبره وفي الكلا جنوب
غرب المطار اذا هذه خارطه الاشتباكات بهذه
النقطه اما مشاهدينا في ام درمان في ام
درمان غربي النيل توجد اشتباكات متفرقه
بين الطرفين اذا
تحديدا الاشتباكات تنحصر هنا حول مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد هنا بهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين هنا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول بانها تسيطر على هذه
النقطه وتسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بينما يسيطر الجيش على محتوى
البث عبر محطه خارجيه اما النقطه الخامسه
فهي في الخرطوم بحري الوضع هنا هادئ قليلا
واهدئ طبعا من الخرطوم لكنه يبقى محتدما
وقبل يومين كما تبعنا خرج سجناء من هذه
النقطه تحديدا
هي سجن كوبر والذي يعتبر من اشهر السجون
واكبر السجون في الخرطوم بحري بعدما قالت
الشرطه انها اضطرت لفعل ذلك بسبب انقطاع
خدمات المياه والكهرباء التي طبعا انقطعت
منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني اذا مشاهدينا
كانت هذه ابرز نقاط المواجهه بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني التي كما قلنا
انها تنحصر الان في داخل العاصمه بمحيط
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري ونقاط اخرى
كما فصلها
من الخرطوم يعود الينا لواء دكتوره امين
اسماعيل مسدود الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز دراسات الدوليه اهلا بك مجددا سياده
اللواء بالمعنى العسكري اذا ما دخلنا في
التفاوض كيف يمكن تصور مخرج
لتواجد وقوه هذه القوات الكامله للجيش او
الدعم السريع في هذه المواقع السياديه
الحساسه
هنالك نوعين من الاشتباكات الان اشتباكات
مطارده وتمشيط في المناطق الطرفيه التي
ذكرت في التقرير سواء كان في الخرطوم
بحريه او درمان باذاعه او في المناطق
الطرفيه تقوم القوات المسلحه الان بعمليات
تمشيط وتطهير لهذه المناطق لانه اعداد من
الدعم السريع اتجهت الى المناطق السكنيه
النوع الثاني من الاشتباكات هو المناوره
في منطقه الوصف الخرطوم قياده العامه
والمطار والقصر الرئاسي تعامل قوات الدعم
السريع اثبات انها موجوده لانها فقدت كثير
من هذه المواقع
وابتعدت كثيرا من المحيط الوسط القرطوم
لذلك اذا جاءت وفق النار تبقى القوات
اماكنها بيتم الفصل بيناته بيكون هنالك
مراقدين ايضا ربما تحدد اللجنه العسكريه
المختصه تجميع القوات وعودتها الى مواقعها
هنالك اجابات فنيه كثيره بتقوم بها اللجنه
العسكريه المختصه بالتفاوض وفي اطلاق
النار الى ان يتم اعداد جدول
باجنده المفاوضات وهذا امر يحتاج طبعا الى
ترتيب ولا وجود خبراء ووجود اطراف من
الجانبين لكن الان العمليات التمشيط
والتطهير القوات المسلحه مستمره الهدنه
القوات المسلحه ولكن هنالك
منذ الامس تم خرج الهدنه واليوم القوات
الدعم السريع وبالتالي هي تصدر بيانات
بانها تسيطر وتحاول ان تسيطر على بعض
المناطق
ناسيه انها تقرا الهدنه وهذا لا يوجد قبول
من الغطاء باعتبار انه في فقد الغياب
والسيطره ما بين قيادات وما بين المجموعات
الموجوده الان سواء كان في الاسواق او
المناطق التقنيه
او متفائل بخصوص طول امد المعركه مع
دخولها الكل هذه القوه على الخط
امد المعركه طبعا بسبب التركيز من القوات
المسلحه حقيقه لعدم اصابه المناطق السكنيه
والسكان وعدم استخدام كل القوه المتوفره
الان بيتم استخدامها هو ممكنه بتركيز
بعمليات تطوير عمليات شارمان من الامدادات
هذا هو السبب الذي يكون اطال هذه
الاشتباكات ولكن في النهايه لا يصح الا
الصحيح اي قوات متمرده ستجد نفسها مطوقه
وتجد نفسها مطارده في كل الاتجاهات شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور امين اسماعيل مسدوب الخبير
الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز دراسات الدوليه
تحياتي اليك
هذا واظهرت صور متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحركا لقوات كبيره من الجيش الى
الخرطوم وافادت مصادر بان تلك القوات
تحركت من ولايات الجزيره والنيل الابيض
ونهر النيل
[موسيقى]
وقف ما وقف انا مواطنين مسالمين دارين
ياكلوا لقمه الايش نمشي وين المشكله بقى
خطيره علينا
[موسيقى]
ومغلي كل حاجه يعني الناس
المساكين
اليوم باليوم
[تصفيق]
في الكرسي انا الدائري منكم بس تهزوا
تستبقوا
مع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقف اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخروقات بالاضافه الى عمليات
القصف العشوائي التي اسفرت عن مقتل مدنيين
بينهم امريكي هو الثاني حتى الان واكد
البيت الابيض على مواصله العمل لتامين
خروج كل مواطن امريكي يريد مغادره الاراضي
السودانيه
من جهته قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
لويس ميغل بوانو ان الاتحاد يرحب بالهدنه
الانسانيه في السودان ولكنه يريد الوصول
الى وقف اطلاق نار دائم
الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه الانسانيه في
السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع ولكن صحيح
هناك اعلانات هنا هناك لاختراقات
لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر دعواتنا لنطاق
المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت النار
دائم
[تصفيق]
كل جارين جارين ماشيين الهجوم
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين قال لهم يمشي السله اهو فتحوا لهم
المخازن بتاعه السلاح بتاعه شرطه المحليه
شرطه المحليه للمواطنين العاديين دايرين
يمشوا ياخذوا لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه
لانه ما في قوه يعني تحميم اي زول يمشي
يشيل لكم يحمي نفسه
اصح في مقداد حسن من اندرمان اهلا بك
الوضع الان عندك
مع
الهدوء النسبي
ويعني عوده الحياه الطبيعيه للجزء الشمالي
في منطقه الثوره هنالك
لان هذا هذه المنطقه قليلا من مواقع
التجاريه التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات
هنالك ايضا لاحظ مع اثناء دولتنا في هذا
اليوم هنالك صوابير كبيره جدا
للوقود من التي التي تستخدم السيارات
الوقود وهنالك ايضا فواتير يثيره في بعض
المناطق في المخازن وهنالك اقبال كبير
حتى
يؤمن المواطنين
المواد الغذائيه التي توجد في حاله
التجاريه هي بالاصل في المخازن او في
الرقوق والى ما انتهى هذا المحبوب كما قال
لنا بعض المسؤولين من هذه اللحام
مشكله كبيره لانجاب
المحال لان كم هي المده الزمنيه التي
يتوقع فيها ان يستمر يعني هذا المخزون
بالوجود على ارفف المحل التجاريه
قد يشمل قليلا لان هنالك كثير من المحلات
الاداريه قد اغلقت ابوابها وانهم يخشون
ارتفاع الاسعار الكبير الذي صاحب
انقطاع الامداد منهم لكن
بتضرر المنطقه الصناعيه بحري والتي هي
تعتبر من المناطق الاستراتيجيه التي تؤمن
الامن الغذائي وتموت جميع مناطق السودان
بتدمرها وتعرضها لهذا النحل المستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه قد يفاقد من مشكله الغذائي
ايضا من مشكله
لان منطقه البحري تقع بها بعض
المصانع والمخازن وشركات الادويه التي
تؤمن نسبه كبيره جدا من الادويه في
السودان وكذلك قد يواجه اصحاب الصيدليات
التي تعمل على قلتها فبيواجه مشكله كبيره
جدا الادويه التي تصاحب الضغط والسكري مع
ان الكثير من المحلات الاداريه اغلقت
ابوابها لزياده الخلافه الامني ونسبه لذلك
خوف المواطنين الا بعض المهن في اتاحات
قليله جدا من النهار لكن على العموم منطقه
ام درمان على غير العاده شهيده الصباح هذا
اليوم اشتباكات
وسماع لمضادات الطائرات في المناطق
السياديه كما
ذكرتا وعلى العموم هي اقل خطوره من منطقه
البحر منطقه الخرطوم باعتبارها
منطقه كبيره
تمتد من شمال مدينه بحري وحتى جنوب ما
يواجه جنوبيه وهي الجغرافيه تعتبر
هي كبيره فان الحركه تم فيها بشكل طبيعي
في المناطقيه
الحركه هذه على الارض في الشوارع
كيف يعني يفعل الناس ذلك باي ظروف وباي
شروط ومن
له من يقيم نقاط التفتيش من له السيطره
على الارض ام انه الانقسام سيد الموقف
الطريقه الذي يقع ضرب مدينه المهندسين
هنالك
حتى تذكر شمالي
وكذلك هنالك تمركز بقوات
الاذاعه العامه
اما في السلاح المهندسين
وانتشار كبير
مع تاكيد
القوات الجيش المسلحه بحسب في منطقه
المهندسين كان هنالك تمشيط للشوارع
الداخليه
الاشتباكات في المنطقه الغربيه لهذا الحي
اللي هو الذي يقع بين يقع الارض الفلاحه
المهندسين هنالك
انقسام في على الارض لكن
يعني مقارنه بمدينه الحكومه وشمال ومدينه
البحري في اقل
اشتراكا في من حيث المواجهات المسلحه
فبالنسبه للوضع الصحي في مدينه فهي تعاني
كثيرا هنالك الكثير من النداءات من
الكوادر الطبيه على قلها هنالك هم الان
يعملون في ظروف صعبه للغايه لكن الجداءات
مستمره من الكوادر الطبيه التي تعمل مثل
المستشفيات
ولكن اين يعني في اي منشات اساسيه لا تزال
تعمل على الصعيد الصحي والاستشفائي بخصوص
ام درمان تحديدا
نعم بحسب النقابه بحسب نقابه الاطباء
التمهيديه
هنالك مستشفيات حكوميه ما زالت تعمل
كمستشفى ام درمان الذي اطلق الى ان هذا
اليوم لان
الوضع وضع الكادر السلبي يعاني كثيرا
هنالك مراكز تم قصفها
وتمركز الرومي الذي كان بالامس بنهار
الامس وقعت
بحسب روايه موجودين انها ربما تكون مضاد
للطيران وقع في هذا المركز يؤدى الى اصابه
اكثر من 13 شخصا اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات
التي ما زالت تقدم قمه بحسب لجنه الاطباء
التمثيليه او نقابه الاطباء مستشفى البقعه
ومستشفى والحكيم والهلال وقطر وهو جميعها
تقع بالقرب من مناطق الاشتباك الى يضم
المواطنين انهم سيعانون صعوبه
الدخول الى تلك المناطق حفاظا على على
سلامته
والمزيد من الاخبار عن الخسائر البشريه
رويتر ستانقل عن مسؤول السوري في السفاره
السوريه في السودان مقتل 15 سوريا في هذه
الاشتباكات نقلا عن شام اف ام بخصوص هذا
الموضوع مقداد في ام درمان هل نشهد ما
شهدناه سابقا في الايام الماضيه من انتشار
لجثث ولاصابات في الشوارع لا تجد من يعني
طريقها الى المستشفيات
بحسب الشهور عيانه بنتحدث
لا لا لا لا توجد هنالك صوره واضحه ربما
تكون هنالك بعض المناطق التي
تشهدان بصوره طبيعيه وربما تم اخلائها لكن
حتى لا توجد بيانات الرقميه لهذا المعدنيه
هنالك هنالك اصابات
تحدث فيها بعض الوسائد وبعض المواطنين لكن
على العموم الوضع الصحي ربما يعتبر اقل
ضررا من الخرطوم
ما الوزارات والمؤسسات الرسميه الاساسيه
التي يستطيع المواطن السوداني ان يلاحظ
انها لا تزال قادره على القيام ببعض على
الاقل من دورها
الاتحاديه ونقابه التمهيديه لراف وكذلك
الذين المركزيه في تساء تحاول ان تبدو
الخساره هذه الظروف الامنيه
الصعبه للغايه وما زالت النداءات لفتح
مسارات امنه وكذلك تحديدها الجغرافيا حتى
يستطيع
الطبي
الوصول الى المناطق التي ربما تحتاج رعايه
طبيه اوليه وربما تحتاج كذلك ثلاث الامداد
دواء لذلك تتجدد الدعوات من الجهات
المعنيه
بالضروره فتح نترات امنه حتى تقوم الكراج
الطبيه على الاقل ان تصل الى مناطق الحيله
ومناطق الاشتباكات التي
تقال جرحى وقتلها يتطلب الوصول الاول
شكرا جزيلا لك الصحه في مقداد حسن من ام
درمان على كل هذه المعلومات والتوضيحات
تحياتي اليك
وفي مسلسل المعاناه للسودانيين المدنيين
يشكون من رصاص الدشكر الروسي ويقولون انه
يخترق جدران المنازل ويصيبهم باصابات
بالغه
صمم في الثلاثينات من القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدرا رمي الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
في السودان الى وقف القتال في البلاد
مشددا على ان القتال لن يكون حلا لصراع
بين القوتين دعا قاده السودان لجعل مصالح
شعبهم اولويه وان يقوموا باسكات اسلحتهم
فورا
كانت بريطانيا عبرت عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفقا مره
اخرى بالوفاء في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريعه الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه
الى السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وضمان حمايه المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني وكذلك الطبيه
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
قال مراسل العربيه ان نحو سبع طائرات
عسكريه تصل يوميا الى بورتسودان للاجلاء
بالتنسيق مع الجيش هذا ووصلت احدى طائرات
الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله
باثنين شخصا كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى
ليبيا عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه
تبدا بالانتقال بالحافلات الى بورتسودان
ثم الى مدينه جده وصولا الى المحطه
الاخيره في طرابلس واستقبل مطار معيتيجا
الدولي 105 من افراد الجاليه الليبيه في
السودان بعد اجلائهم واكدت الجزائر ان 13
فلسطينيا واثنين سوريا وعددا اخر من
الرعايه بالخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورت
سودان
جاؤوها بحثا عن فرص جديده وهاهم يغادرونها
للنجاه بحياتهم نحو عشره الاف شخص من
خمسين دوله حول العالم تم اجلائهم حتى
الان منهم 2250 من جنسيات مختلفه نقل بحرا
من ميناء بورتسودان الى بناء جده في
السعوديه
اكثر من 1500 مواطن مصري والمئات من
المواطنين العرب عاشوا سفر الجلاء الاصعب
اكثر من الف كيلو متر بحافلات نقلتهم الى
الحدود ونعب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا
دلوقتي جينا وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه
عشان دي عبره لحد السمكاتها يا بورسودان
اخذنا يومين
وسجلنا هنا والله البحريه السعوديه بارك
الله فيهم
400 فرنسي ومئه الماني وغيرهم من الدول
الاجنبيه تنقل جوا من مطار عسكري قرب
الخرطوم الى مطار جيبوتي بعثه دبلوماسيه
امريكيه وروسيه واسيويه وجدت هي الاخرى
السبيلا للنجاه من حرب السودان معظم هؤلاء
النازحين كانوا محرك النهضه ماموله في
السودان اطباء ومهندسون ومعلمون قد عجله
تنميه تعص
خارج الحدود لكن ماذا عن السودانيين
الراغبين في النجاه بحياتهم لقد وقعوا
فريسه تجار
الحربات عمره في التذاكر
وكل يوم
يقول هؤلاء الشبان ان تذكره الحافله وصلت
الى 350 دولارا سوق حرب سوداء بدات تلوح
في الافق نشاهد لعائلات نزحت الى تشاد
بحثا عن امن وغذاء تذكر بالسنوات مجاعه
وجفاف ولكن هذه المره السبب البشر وليس
قله المطر
كثيرا ما اصطدم السودانيون بمصطلح الجهه
الثالثه عند محاوله البحث عن المتسبب في
بعض من الاحداث التي مرت على البلاد حينها
كانت مختلف الاطراف ترمي التهمه على هذا
الطرف المجهول اليوم يعود هذا المصطلح
للواجهه فمن هي الجهه الثالثه
المواجهات تتكرر في السودان والمتهم واحد
قبل اسقاط الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قتل
متظاهرون مناوون له عام 2019 والقيت
التهمه على جهه ثالثه بحسب مدير المخابرات
انذاك صلاح عبدالله غوش
انتهى حكم البشير وبعد اشهر من التنازع
السياسي بين المكونين المدني والعسكري حدث
فضه اعتصام القياده ايضا تكرر قتل
المتظاهرين وشماعه التي تلقى عليها التهم
لم تتغير
في وقتنا الحاضر هذه الجهه الثالثه ايضا
هي المتهمه باداره النزاع اول وقوف وراء
النزاع العسكري الدائر وهي قوه او فلول
نظام البشير السابق طرف النزاع تبادل
الاتهامات وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ان من
يدير الحرب على قواته هم قيادات في حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل حزب الرئيس السابق
عمر البشير واعتبر انهم من يقودون الجيش
للحركه الاسلامي مجموعه بالحركه الاسلاميه
على راسهم على كردي اسامه عبد الله مجموعه
من الاعتذار مجموعه من الاسلام
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان رد
ايضا عبر العربيه مشيرا الى ان الجيش
السوداني وكاي جيش في العالم هدفه ضمان
وحده الدوله بشكل عام وليس العمل من اجل
شخص او جهه ما اذا
[موسيقى]
كذب ولا الجميع يعلم ذلك نحن قوات مسلحه
نعمل احترافيه وواجبنا حمايه السودان حتى
معظم من نرد هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه
ويعلم انه انها كلمه باطن فيها
الاتهامات ايضا صدرت من بعض القوى
السياسيه لاتباع النظام السابق بالوقوف
وراء نشوب الحرب واستمرارها ومحاوله
تصعيدها خاصه وان العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه هي التي اقصت حزب المؤتمر
وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتداول
سودانيون ما يفيد بان انصار البشير يرفضون
صراحه قوات الدعم السريع لكنهم في ذات
الوقت يهددون بالوقوف بوجه الجيش حاله
توقف الحرب والهدف واحد مصلحه فلول البشير
حسن جوليد العربيه
اذا الاخبار عاجله جديده على خط الازمه
الجيش السوداني يقول ان رئيس مجلس السياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان تسلم مبادره ايجاد لحل
الازمه وافق عليها مبدئيا اذا هذه
المبادره تتضمن تمديد الهدنه الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه وهي طبعا منظمه تضم عددا من
الدول الافريقيه منظمه التنميه الحكوميه
الافريقيه وفيها عدد من الدول منها
السودان وجنوب السودان وكينيا اوغندا
صوماليا اثيوبيا كينيا الى ما هنالك وهي
مهمه جدا على خط الازمه كانت على خط
الازمه السودانيه في السابق وطرحت العديد
من المبادرات وهي تطرح مبادره جديده الان
مبادره اذا افريقيه من الايجاد تنص على
افاده ممثلين للجيش والدعم السريع الى
جوبا عاصمه جنوب السودان
لمناقشتها اذا كنا استمعنا
الى الكثير من التصريحات عن الدخول على خط
الازمه عن القبول عن الرفض الى ما هناك
بانتظار المزيد من المواقف الان بدات هذه
المواقف تتضح اكثر فاكثر الجيش يقول ان
مبادره الايجاد تنص على افاد ممثلين للجيش
والدعم السريع الى جبل لمناقشتها لنا ان
نتصور الان ان الامور ان مضت كما تقول
المبادره وفقا للجيش السوداني تتضمن تمديد
الهدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه ربما في
خلالها او لاحقا يتم ارسال المفادين من
قبل الطرفين من قبل الجيش والدعم السريع
الى جوبا لمناقشه المبادره مبادره الايجاد
وعلى ماذا ستنص تحديدا وان كانت طرفان
سيقبلان بها ان كان سيتم ارسال مراقبين
دوليين لمراقبه وقف لاطلاق النار مثلا ان
كان سيتم الجلوس مباشره على طاوله التفاوض
بين الطرفين مع بقيه القوى السياسيه ام لا
سنحاول التعرف على التفاصيل لكل ذلك عندما
يكون لدينا اخبار اخرى عن طبيعه هذه
المبادره عن موقف الجيش كيف سيتعامل معها
وعن موقف قوات الدعم السريع كذلك الجيش
يعطي ايضا تفاصيل عن هذه المبادره
وبانتظار ان يحدد هذه يعني ان يحدد الجيش
يقول الان انه البرهان تسلم المبادره
ووافق عليها مبدئيا اذا اعلن واعطى بعض
التفاصيل عنها وقال انه وافق عليها مبدئيا
ربما انتظار موقف الطرف الاخر نحن بانتظار
موقف قوه الدعم السريع اذا مبادره ايجاد
تتضمن اثنتين وسبعين ساعه هدنه تمديدا
للهدنه القائمه حاليا بانتظار المزيد من
المعلومات نتحدث الى مراسلنا سالم الهاشمي
من ام درمان سالم كيف يمكن وصف الوضع على
الارض الان عندك
سالم نعم طاهر بكل المشاهدين بدايه الوضع
الارض كان قبل الساعه كانت تتجدد
الاشتباكات في مختلف مناطق الخرطوم
الولايات الخرطوم لكن هنا في المكان الذي
انا متواجد فيه الان
الى صوت مضادات الطائرات قبل ساعه ونصف
ساعتين وايضا وصلتنا العديد من الانباء ان
هناك اشتباكات جهه بالقرب من جسر عند
البشير وهو في شارع
العارضه وهو طريق يقع جنوب غربي ام درمان
او في اتجاه المتجه الى الجهه الغربيه من
ام درمان كذلك في جهه صالحه ايضا مجموعه
من اصوات المدافع الثقيله والخفيفه وفي
بدا السبيل كذلك وهي كل هذه المناطق
متقاربه كذلك في المهندسين ليست بعيدا من
بعضها البعض في الاتجاه الجنوب والجنوب
الغربي من جهه ام درمان هنا ستمركز اكثر
الاشتباكات ويضاف اليها ما نستمع اليه هنا
سالم تسمعني
الان اسمعك تفضل
نعم وهذا ايضا من الامور المهمه وهو
التذبذب شبكات الاتصالات الذي يحيط بكل
الاتصالات في اللحظات او في اليومين
الماضي تحديدا لكن بالحديث عن موضوع
الهدمات التي توالت نلاحظ انه من بين هدنه
لهدنه هنالك هدوء نسبي وهذا الهدوء تزداد
ساعاته من هدنه الى هدنه ربما يعني هذا من
الامور المبشره في ان كل هدنه وراء هدنه
فيها فتره الهدوء المشبه هذه تزداد عدد
ساعاتها كانت في المرات الاولى فقط
يعني في بدايه هذه الاشتباكات لا تزيد عن
ساعه او ساعتين على نحن نتحدث عن اربع
ساعات خمس ساعات فيها هدوء نسبي في كل
انحاء الولايه هذا الامر ربما ايضا يكون
معين الى ان تكون هذه الهدنه قادره على
اقناع الطرفين لوقف اطلاق النار
طيب الوضع الانساني الت
غذيه الصحي على مختلف هذه المستويات هل
يسوء ام انه في جهات قادره على امداد
السوق بمتطلباته الاساسيه
نعم هنا في المناطق التي دائما ما تقسم
على ان هناك مناطق اشتباكات عاليه وهناك
مناطق اقل حده في الاشتباكات المناطق
الاقل الحين نسبيا للمناطق الاشتباكات
ليعاني فيها المواطنون من هذا الامر
ومساله شح الانذائي وعدم القدره على ايصال
هذه امدادات بشكل جيد يضاف اليها معضله في
الحركه كذلك لان هذه المناطق تصبح بعد ذلك
معزوله لانها محاطه كذلك بمناطق فيها
اشتباكات هذا الامر يعني يجعل من الصعوبه
ايصال الامداد الغذائي امداد الوقود
وغيرها من المتعلقات بهذه المناطق
واحتياجاتها عدا حركه قليله جدا يحصل
انفراج احيانا في احد القصور يتم فتح هذه
البشور بشكل مع مثلا فتحدث هذه الحركه
نسبيا نستطيع ان نقول ان هنالك لكن واحده
من الامور التي لمسناها اليوم وهي ربما
تشكل معض نعم المستقبل وهي موضوع القمح
والدقيق
الان هناك انسياب بالفعل
لمواد يعني مواد غذائيه بما فيها القمح
والدقيق لكن كل من يحملون القمح والدقيق
يتحدثون ان هنالك
المطاحن الرئيسيه في السودان هي الان ان
لم تكن خارج الخدمه فهي لا يستطيع الوصول
اليها حتى الان وتقع في المنطقه الصناعيه
ومحاطه بالعديد من الاشتباكات هذا
بالاضافه الى انها تعرضت لعمليات نهم في
منطقه بحريه وهي معروفه سين وسيله
تعرضت لنهاب وسلب وربما يعني اذا كان
الاعتماد سيكون على واحده من المطاحن فقط
وهي التي تعمل الان وتستطيع ايصال هذه
المبادات لم تستطع ان تصمت طويلا في تغطيه
هذه المناطق كامله وايضا ربما ايضا في
يعني مساله الطريق كذلك الوقود كل هذه
المعضلات ربما تشكل مشكله في وقت ما وهذا
نحن نربطه بشكل مباشر لان السودانيون في
العاصمه الخرطوم بالذات يعتمدون اعتمادا
كليا على رغيف الخبز الذي يعتمد بكل تاكيد
على القمح طبعا شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه
تحياتي اليك
اذا ما زلنا مع مبادره الايجاد التي تحدث
عنها الجيش السوداني في بيانه قال ان
البرهان تسلم المبادره وهي تمخضت عن
الاجتماع الذي انعقد في وقت سابق بين
رؤساء دول المنظمه وتقرر فيه تكليف رؤساء
كينيا جيبوتي وجنوب السودان بالعمل على
مقترحات حلول للازمه الحاليه اذا بانتظار
تجديد او تمديد الهدنه هدنه الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه وافاد ممثل عن كل طرف من
القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع الى
عاصمه جنوب السودان جوبا بغرض التفاوض
بانتظار المزيد من التفاصيل حول ذلك نتابع
في تغطيتنا فاضافه الى فشل الهدن
الانسانيه في السودان واستمرار القتال جاء
خطر دخول مجموعه عسكريه خاصه على الخط
ليعقد المعادله ويزيد من مخاوف الجهات
الدوليه
مع دعوات وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
والهدنات التي لا تدوم الا قليله تصاعدت
مخاوف حول دخول مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه
الروسيه على خط الصراع دعم باسلحه من قوات
فاجنر ما هي دقه هذه المعلومات اولا
بالنسبه لكم سياده الفريق
نحن نتحرر من دقه هذه المعلومات كان هذا
رد البرهان على سؤال حول وجود فاغنر في
السودان في لقاء مع قناه العربيه في
الثاني والعشرين من هذا الشهر اما دجلو
فعند سؤاله عن علاقه الدعم السريع
بالمجموعه العسكريه الخاصه فقد انكر
اول المعبرين عن قلقهم من وجود محتمل
لمرتزقه فاغنر كان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن
مقابل القلق الامريكي موقف رسمي روسي
يتجاهل المخاوف الامريكيه
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف اعتبر
تعامل الدول الافريقيه مع فاغنر كشركه
خاصه شانا داخليا وان لها الحق في ذلك
ولكن لم يتبين حتى الان ما اذا كان
لمرتزقه
وجود على الميدان في السودان انس النماسي
العربيه
من لندن الصحفيه والاعلاميه السودانيه
دكتوره رؤى عربي اهلا بك معنا دكتوره معلش
ابدا معك بموضوع المبادره الايجاد هذه هل
تعاولين عليها
مساء الخير لكل المشاهدين والمستمعين
التعويل عليها الان قد يبدو مبكرا لا اعود
عليها كثيرا لان ما زالت الحرب مشتعله بين
الطرفين النزاع اليوم رغم الهدنه شاهدنا
العديد من
الاطلاق الرصاص من قبل الطرفين في منطقه
العيلفون بدات عند الصباح الطائرات كذلك
في منطقه ام درمان القديمه حوالين المبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون
الى مائده التفاوض واحده ولو في خارج
السودان
وهي طبعا خطوه ممكن تكون ايجابيه اذا
التزمت طرفان
انه يكون في حوار جاد قبل الحوار الجاد
يجب ان يكون في ايقاف لاطلاق النار جاد
من الهدن عندما يتم اختراق طوال بيتراشق
البيانات والطرفين النزاع ويتهم احدهما
الاخر يمكن السلوك ده استمر خلال طيله
الفتره اللي فاتت
المحادثات تفشل يعني نامل نامل ان تنجح
ولكن هذا يحصل عاده الان اعود الى موضوع
التقاريرنا السابقه اولا عن موضوع الطرف
الثالث المتهم دائما في الداخل وثانيا عن
موضوع دخول قوه عسكريه اقليميه واجنبيه
على الخط هل توافقين اولا على وجود طرف
ثالث
فرضيه الطرف الثالث هي فرضيه انا بشوف
دائما انها بتنزع المسؤوليه من الاطراف
الحاليه في النزاع يعني في الشارع
السوداني الان من يقاتل الجيش والدعم
السريع ومن خلفهم مثلا احزاب بتدعم شقه
البرهان والجيش واحزاب بتدعم
الدعم السريع
فرضيه انه يكون في الدوله الكيزانيه او
النظام البائد والنظام البائد من صنع
ميليشيات الدعم السريع والنظام البارد
ايضا هو من اتى بالبرهان لانه البرهان هو
اللجنه البشير الامنيه اذا النظام السابق
باقي بطريقه او باخرى من خلال وجوب
العسكريه الموجوده في الساحه الان
بهذه الطريقه تفندين اتهامات الطرفين
لبعضهم البعض
تاكيد ايوه
خصوصا فرضيه انه
حميدتي اللي هي بمبرر لهجوم واصلا انه
بيقول انه من اجل الانتقال الديمقراطي
ومحاربه الكذان وطبعا كلام عاري من الصحه
لانه هي من اصل ميليشيات كانت تقوم
بالاعمال القذره للنظام السابق فكيف تجلب
الديمقراطيه بالنسبه لموضوع فاغنر او
تواجد الروسي في السودان فالدلالات
والاشارات والتقارير تشير الى انه موجودين
في السودان
في ملفات كثيره خصوصا في الذهب السوداني
في منطقه البحر الاحمر في الشركات الروسيه
للتنقيب عن الذهب وكذلك وجودهم في في هذه
المنطقه بسبب القاعده الروسيه المقرر
انشاءه في البحر الاحمر تبقينا معنا لو
تكرمت نعود اليك بعد قليل نذكر بتصريحات
سفير جزر القمر في فرنسا وعضو مبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه الذي كان اكد
في لقاء مع العربيه بان طرفي النزاعوه
فقاع على مبادره افريقيه للتسويه وان هذه
المبادره تتضمن وقفا دائما للنار وان رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي يعتزم زياره الخرطوم
شرطه توفر الظروف الامنيه المناسبه
المكالمتين مع
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع الدولي الى ان يقفوا على
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل ايجاد حل
تلقي
ونستغل وجودك معنا اكثر دكتوره رؤى لنتحدث
عن موضوع المبادره هذه حتى الان تتضمن
تمديدا مقترحا
للهدنه وليس وقفا لاطلاق النار وهذا يعني
جيد ان تم الالتزام به ولكن هل تعتقدين ان
الاطراف التي تعمل على خط هذه الازمه
حاليا
موثوقه بالشكل الكافي من كل الاطراف ويمكن
لها ان تضمن للطرفين ما يريدان يعني ان
يضمناه على الارض لكي يلتزمان
يعني الهدى تم استغلالها بطريقه سيئه من
قبل الطرفين في الحشد سواء من الدعم
السريع او من الجيش وبدايه
المختلفه يمكن حتى ده بيشكك في مصداقيه
الطرفان مع بعضهما البعض
بحاجه الى قوات من هذه الدول مثلا دول
الايجاد
لكي تشرف على اي وقف لاطلاق النار
حتى الاعانات
الحوجات بالنسبه للغذاء والدواء ما قادر
تدخل فاتوقع انه ما زال مبكرا انه يتم
استجلاب قوات بين الخارج لكن
اتوقع انه المفاوضات يجب ان تكون
مع البرهان
بانفصال مع حميدتي قد تاخذ فتره اطول قبل
ان تتوقف هذه الحرب او يتوقف اطلاق النار
ولكن نامل انه يكون في
رغبه يعني كل ممثل يذهب عن القوات المسلحه
وعن قوات الدعم السريع لا تحصل المفاوضات
بينهما مباشره حتى في جوبا
اعتقد انه من المبكر انه يحدث مفاوضات
مباشره بين الطرفين
نحن نتحدث عن ممثليهما وليس عنهما شخصيا
ممثليهما نعم احنا برضو سمعنا اخبار انه
اصلا التفاوض بدا بيناتهم لكن ما يتم
اثبات هذه
الاقاويل لانه الطرفين يعني بعدين متشنجين
من خلال اللقاءات اللي قاموا بها الاثنين
مع
قناتكم بالذات حميدتي يعني حميتي يهدد
بقتل البرهان
والوعيد على كل حال الى وجهتي النظر في
هذا الاطار
ونشكرك على وجودك معنا دكتوره عربي
الصحفيه والاعلاميه السودانيه شكرا جزيلا
لك
الى موجز لاهم الاخبار الدوليه الان بعد
اول محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني مع
نظيره
الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه
انها سترسل ممثلا خاصا عن بكين مسؤولا عن
الشؤون الاوروبيه الاسيويه الى اوكرانيا
ودول اخرى لاجراء محدثات معمقه مع جميع
الاطراف من اجل التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
وقال مسؤول صيني ان محادثات
تتم عن موقف تنمو عن موقف الصين الموضوعي
والمحايد ازاء الشؤون الدوليه
وعن احساسها بالمسؤوليه
من جهته قال رئيس الاوكراني خلال المكالمه
انه لا سلام مع روسيا على حساب التنازلات
الاقليميه من جانبه قال الرئيس الصيني ان
بلاده ستقوم بارسال ممثل خاص عن الحكومه
الصينيه الى اوكرانيا لاجراء اتصال مع
جميع اطراف النزاع للتوصل الى حل بشان
تسويه الازمه السياسيه الاوكرانيه مؤكدا
ان بلاده لن تختار ان تكون متفرجا على
الازمه الاوكرانيه
اوضح مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده لنادي
انه لم يتم احراز تقدم حقيقي لحل القضايا
التي اثارتها موسكو بشان اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود والذي من المقرر
ان ينتهي العمل به الشهر المقبل مشيرا الى
ان روسيا لن توافق على التمديد ما لم يقم
الغرب بازاله العراقيل التي تعيق الصادرات
الروسيه من الحبوب والاسمده
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان القوات
البيلاروسيه يتم تدريبها في روسيا لتشغيل
انظمه صواريخ اسكندر بحسب الوزاره فان
الاطقما تتدرب في مكان غير محدد جنوب
روسيا منذ الثالث من الشهر الجاري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلنت روسيا ترضى عشره دبلوماسيين
النرويجيين ردا على طرد اوسلو خمسه عشر
موظفا في السفاره الروسيه لديها وقالت
الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان انها استدعت
السفيرا النرويجي لدى موسكو وابلغته
بعمليات الطرد هذه في اطار اجراءات
انتقاميه معبره عن احتجاجها الشديد على
طرد النرويج دبلوماسيين روسا
اعلنت وزاره العدل الامريكيه ان السلطات
الرومانيه اعتقلت اللبناني محمد ابراهيم
بزي احد ابرز ممولي حزب الله والمدرج على
لائحه الارهاب الامريكيه منذ 2018 لدى
وصوله الى مطار بوخارست ويحمل بزي الذي
يبلغ من العمر 58 عاما الجنسيتين
اللبنانيه والبلجيكيه كانت واشنطن رصدت
مكافاه بعشره ملايين دولار مقابل معلومات
عن مكان تواجد بزي الذي ساهم بدعم حزب
الله وتمويله على مدى السنوات وفق وزاره
العدل الامريكيه
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني انه ليس من
المرجح تغلب على كل الخلافات مع الصين الا
انه توقع ان تحافظ تكيين على التزاماتها
الدوليه
يجب ان نتعامل مع الصين عند الضروره وان
نكون واقعيين بشان التعامل مع الصين وهذا
يعني عدم التراجع عن مبدا واضح لا نتوقع
ان يتم التغلب على خلافاتنا مع الصين
بسرعه لكننا نتوقع ان تراعي الصين
القوانين والالتزامات التي تعهدت بها
نعود الى استكمال تغطيه احداث السودان
وتطوراته مع صهيب شراير بعد قليل الى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات